A plus 3 times a plus 5 is correct, great work if you figured that one out. We
can start by factoring the two numerators. The factors of negative 5 that sum to
4 are positive 5 and negative 1. For the second numerator we want to find
factors of 15 that sum to 8, those are positive 5 and positive 3. We know we're
going to multiply these two fractions together, so we'll multiply every factor
in the numerator and every factor in the denominator. We can think of this
denominator as 1 times the quantity a plus 5. The same is true for this one, 1
times a minus 1. I show this so that way we can understand we 're really
multiplying these two factors together. This is why I use the parentheses around
these two expressions. We know a plus 5 divided by a plus 5 equals 1 and a minus
1 divided by a minus 1 also equals 1. This leaves us with a plus 5 times a plus
3 in the numerator divided by 1 in the denominator. Anything divided by 1 is
itself so this is our answer.